foreign
Sports goats to other parts of the world
last month for the first time in three
decades the country's inflation rate
increased to more than 100 percent
there is lots of instability in the
prices we pay in transport food and
grass and different exchange rates the
government implements it gets very
complicated
Argentina has also been implementing
exchange rate controls because of a
shortage of dollars
people like Betis I pray that the
official exchange rate that is much
lower than the market value of the
dollar the government has been applying
different exchange rates to different
sectors to encourage producers to sell
their products the latest one is known
as the dollar aggro that will benefit
the rural sector in this country the
main objective is to help replenish this
country's impoverished coffers but most
people say that this is a temporary
solution that won't solve Argentina's
endemic economic troubles
says the government measures are not
enough beneficiary
this only benefits a small group of
people there are so many dollars that I
have lost track it doesn't help small
producers like us but the big ones and
those involved in large agribusiness the
government is trying to grab dollars and
money in any way they can
a top exporter of soy and corn the
country is dealing with a historic
drought it is having a huge impact on
the economy complicating access to
foreign currency and forcing yet another
round of negotiations with the IMF over
a 44 billion dollar loan
there are problems that worry us very
much and we inherited a huge debt with
the IMF but we were conscious to include
a clause that if the economic situation
changes for reasons outside politics
then we will have to rethink the program
and that's what we are doing now
poverty rates on the rise and Financial
instability economies say the situation
could easily deteriorate in the lead-up
to the elections in October I see a risk
of a situation getting worse the lack of
Finance inflation pressures the degree
of distortions that the government have
to engage in in order to postpone the
adjustment has been getting deeper
Argentina's productive sector is
struggling to cope with soaring
inflation drought and political
uncertainty for now it seems no measure
will have the impact that people in the
country
urgently needs
well still ahead here on the news